We Won't be doing that today. Tomorrow
tomorrow works.
Think about finally having everything you always wanted
I can save today
But you can save the world
Steve?
Diana?
You know you need to do
that's just a trashcan is just a trash
can yeah yeah.
Welcome back everyone is
Charlie this is going to be my new Wonder
Woman 1984 trailer video we also have a
special Justice League twenty20 one
announcement that's really cool and some
more Wonder Woman 1984 footage that
they're going to be dropping really soon
that I'll explain so if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos will do a new Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave all your
predictions for Wonder Woman 1984 on the
video so just going down the list
starting with number 5 Warner Brothers
just made a couple big announcements
about its movies for the next year it
shifted everything again by a couple
weeks some movies more than that Wonder
Woman 1984 is now going to come out October
2nd this year instead of August that's
because mr. Batman Dark Knight himself
Christopher Nolan's movie Tennant got
delayed by a couple weeks so all the
other movies that Warner Brothers
releasing after that just got moved down
the bench by a couple more weeks
themselves now we can joke that Wonder
Woman 1984 is the New Mutants of DC
movies it's had at least three different
release dates so far and even when they
made the announcement yesterday too they
tweeted out this picture that had all
these Thanksgiving messages on them like
they had planned on releasing Wonder
Woman 1984 Thanksgiving this year but
then changed their minds to October as
chaotic as that sounds don't worry we're
still going to get to see the movie is just
being bumped by a couple weeks into
October so it's not that bad it could
have been way WAY worse the special new
Wonder Woman 1984 footage that they're
going to be releasing is actually going to be
coming in July around July 17th when
they rerelease inception in theaters
another big Christopher Nolan movie
they're trying to get people to go back
to movie theaters so they're
re-releasing a ton of really really big
movies it'll be brand new Wonder Woman
1984 footage from the movie so whatever
it is I will totally do a video for
breaking down all the Easter eggs they
didn't say whether or not they're going to
post that online so you probably wind up
having to go to the theater to see it DC
is also doing a big special virtual
Comic Con event later this summer
separate from the actual comic-con where
they'll do panels from the upcoming
Suicide Squad movie with James Gunn and
a bunch of Wonder Woman 1984 stuff a
bunch of the Batman stuff probably so
that'll all be separate maybe some other
trailers from that too but number 4 the
really cool announcement about Justice
League Nick
we'll get you even more hyped up if
you're already excited about the Snider
cut is that because of the way all these
movie releases are changing Justice
League is probably going to wind up being
Warner Brothers biggest spring early
summer movie Blockbuster and it's not
even being released in theaters I've
already done a couple videos about how
that version of Justice League is going to
be radically different than the
theatrical cut so I'll link them at the
end of this it'll be a totally different
movie and speaking of Wonder Woman gal
gadot she and the other Justice League
actors will be coming back to record new
dialogue for Zack Snyder's alternate
footage the new version of the movie is
going to be over four hours long and
they're saying around 75% of that is
probably going to be totally different
story and footage than the theatrical
cut so there is a lot of extra dialogue
that needs to be recorded for say like
the dark side scenes who they're putting
back in the movie
thankfully Dark Side is coming back and
the other scenes just to stitch
everything together in a way that makes
sense
but right now the report is that they're
going to be breaking the movie up into
six different parts and airing it on HBO
max like a miniseries next summer so
it's basically going to be Warner
Brothers biggest summer blockbuster
event no official release date yet but
it'll probably be sometime between late
April to early June and it would just
run for six weeks six different episodes
if you don't have HBO max right now I'm
sure they're going to run some promo and
they'll be dropping trailers for that
before the end of the year and early
next year too just to get people even
more hyped up like please subscribe to
HBO max to get this amazing thing we're
releasing but number three none of that
stuff is going to connect to what's
happening in Wonder Woman 1984 the big
hope for the Justice League Snider cut
is that if it's successful as it seems
like it's going to be Warner Brothers
we'll just be open to continuing that
part of the DC Universe with other types
of stories and projects like that on HBO
max in the future if they announced that
they're doing the same thing for Suicide
Squad and changing that with an
alternate cut of the film I'll do a
video for that too but thus far they've
only said that they're doing it for
Justice League right now Wonder Woman
1984 and Wonder Woman three are only
loosely connected to the previous
Justice League DC EU movies in the sense
that it's still gal gadot playing the
character and in present day she'll
still know Aquaman Batman the flash
cyborg superman in apparently Shazam now
now that she Sam met the Justice League
before the ending of that movie
but the strategy that they're using for
their new DC movies going forward is
that they're letting the directors do
more self-contained movies if they want
so some of the DC movies going forward
will still be connected to Justice
League and some will not to great
examples that on opposite ends of the
spectrum are Shazam 2 in the Batman
movie with Robert Pattinson so if you
didn't see the news a while ago henry
cavill is signing a contract to come
back as Superman Man of Steel in the DC
Universe but crossing over into other
upcoming DC movies he's not signing a
contract for a Man of Steel 2 one of the
movies he would cross over into would be
Shazam 2 I'll do a new Superman movie
video sometime soon too because there was
also a report about what's going on with
that next Superman movie and when Warner
Brothers is planning on actually doing
that on the opposite end of the spectrum
in terms of continuity the Batman movie
with Robert Pattinson is not going to be
connected to Justice League it's going
to be its own self-contained thing it
takes place in the past and Robert
Pattinson isn't supposed to be a prequel
version of Ben Affleck's Batman he's
just supposed to be a younger version of
a Batman number two the new Wonder Woman
1984 stuff is mostly about Wonder Woman
and cheetahs character arc the way that
they're setting up cheetah for possible
future returns and other DC movies or
even Wonder Woman 3 so this is basically
what cheetah looks like in the movie
there been a couple promos that have
been released of what she actually looks
like at various points during the film
but the whole idea is that she slowly
becomes cheetah over the course of the
film so she evolves into the comic book
cheetah form and it actually does look
pretty good on screen Maxwell Lord is
the closest thing to a main villain the
movie has but even he isn't really a
villain in the way that Ares God of War
was the main villain of the first Wonder
Woman movie if you're going into the
movie kind of expecting the end to be
similar to the first Wonder Woman movie
you will be extremely surprised the
movie could not be more different
rewatch the trailer a couple times
notice what's missing from all the
scenes Wonder Woman does not have her
sword with her in present-day and even
when she puts on the special war armor
with the gold wings from the comics she
doesn't have the sword and she doesn't
have her shield at any point during the
trailer just the lasso of truth patty
Jenkins and gal gadot said that she's
not using those the shield or the sword
in the movie because she isn't going to
be
running around chopping body parts off
of anyone no gods
no regular people no metahumans not even
cheetah or Maxwell Lord in it's all part
of the idea that the movie isn't
supposed to be about Wonder Woman
defeating villains or fighting villains
it's all about how Wonder Woman saves
everyone or at least tries to save
everyone number one the whole thing with
the cheetah story arc is that she starts
out as this awkward historian and
archaeologist working with Wonder Woman
at the Museum they become friends and
because Barbara Minerva thinks of
herself as trash she wants nothing more
than to have what she perceives to be
Wonder Woman's power and grace she wants
to be Wonder Woman because of what
Maxwell Lord does with a special black
stone that becomes literally possible
for her so cheetah effectively gains her
cheetah abilities and becomes powerful
like Wonder Woman over the course of the
movie but in the movie because this is
all about the excess and greed of the
80s it's about the metaphors of greed
turning people into monsters but because
it's a comic book movie and you have a
special magical black rock it also
literally turns people into monsters so
that explains how cheetah begins to look
like comic book cheetah over the course
of the film and in terms of her coming
back and future DC movies that would
either be Wonder Woman 3 or another DC
movie but they haven't said specifically
which one it's just the idea that she
could always come back if Kristen Wiig
wants to come back like I said though
the big special new footage that they're
releasing for Wonder Woman 1984 that'll
be sometime around July 17th when they
rerelease inception in theaters they'll
be dropping a bunch of footage for
upcoming Warner Brothers movies Wonder
Woman 1984 is just one of those let me
know in the comments though if they
bring cheetah back in a future DC movie
where do you want her to show up again
there's a bunch of stuff coming up in
the next couple of weeks so I'll try to
do as many videos for everything as
possible as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you should see
all those videos when I post them but
leave all your requests in the comments
below
everyone click here for that Justice
League Snyder cut teaser trailer and
click here for that brand new spider-man
Miles Morales trailer thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!